[Aplausos]
qué vas a hacer con tu vida es una
pregunta que me mantuvo en pánico varios
años qué vas a hacer con tu vida
por miedo por ignorancia y
principalmente por falta de experiencia
es una pregunta que en lugar de hacerme
a mí se le dice al mundo que voy a hacer
con mi vida pues estudia estudia algo
interesante algo que te sirva en la vida
y eso hice estudia arquitectura de
paisaje y en ese aspecto y en muchos
otros deje que el mundo y lo
preestablecido decidieran por mí
debo reconocer que dejarle esa
responsabilidad a otros era mucho más
fácil
así les echaba la culpa por cualquier
cosa a los demás oa las decisiones que
había tomado para cumplir con sus
expectativas en lugar de cumplir con las
mías y tampoco es que supiera realmente
cuáles eran mis expectativas
esas decisiones también me dieron la
oportunidad de saber que el camino que
estaba tomando no era el que yo quería
yo quería otra cosa otra vida otro
estilo
me sentía encerrada en un traje que no
me quedaba así que cuando termine de
estudiar
y empecé a pintar y ni siquiera a pintar
empecé a hacer rayas
en un cuadernito una raya tras otra
este ejercicio se volvió un escape para
mí
me dio la posibilidad de abrir mi mente
a otro lenguaje un lenguaje el cual
había practicado muy poco y con mucho
temor
decidí dedicarme
a la expresión artística
principalmente la pintura la pintura me
llevó a hacer murales y los murales me
llevaron a hacer arte urbano y en ese
momento el mundo se volvió mi lienzo
de alguna manera yo creo que escogí a
este camino para dejar claro que yo era
dueña de mi vida
también probé otras cosas como danza
expresión corporal teatro incluso cine
de todo un poco
simultáneamente
rompí con varias situaciones de mi vida
rompí con relaciones profesionales
personales hasta familiares
en un momento de rebeliones de catarsis
quería dejar claro y no sé ni por qué
que no quería más de lo que había sido
hasta ese momento
sentía yo libre y encantada de la vida
cada vez iba teniendo más confianza en
mi talento y trazo se volvía más certero
vencí por primera vez el miedo que me
había paralizado durante varios años
es increíble la sensación que te da
mandar todo por un poco una sensación de
liberación
de ser ilimitado de poder y lo viví con
euforia enamorada de la vida y del
momento imagínense además estaba yo
ya plasmando lo que querían los muros a
lo largo de la ciudad eran oportunidades
increíbles
pero como toda la vida
la euforia pasó
y el bajón fue bastante gancho
de pronto me vi envuelta en una serie de
situaciones en las cuales nunca imaginé
estar y definitivamente no quería estar
desperté de este gran sueño de libertad
dirigido principalmente por mi ego
y me encontré con una realidad bastante
cruda cruda porque vi por primera vez el
desastre que había creado a nivel
emocional
por primera vez me di cuenta que había
yo lastimado a otros y principalmente me
había lastimado a mí me sentía
completamente ausente
estaba alejada de mis emociones me di
cuenta de mi falta de responsabilidad y
no me refiero a la responsabilidad de
pagar las cuentas o llegar temprano al
trabajo me refiero a mi incapacidad de
responder ante mis decisiones ante mis
emociones
de mis acciones mis pensamientos
y también a mi incapacidad de asumir las
consecuencias de una realidad que yo
había creado
me sentía en conflicto constante con el
mundo sentía que tenía que estar
defendiendo me todo el tiempo
y surgieron varias preguntas la
principal entonces qué significa ser
libre
cómo puedo ser libre de manera
responsable
cómo puedo hacer lo que quiero y de la
manera que quiero y además contribuir
con el entorno
cómo puedo seguir creando sin destruir y
sin destruirme
y entonces pase a un momento de
reflexión y de introspección
por primera vez voltea a verme a mí
misma puede haber una parte de mí que
había tratado de ignorar durante varios
años
voltea a verme donde más me odiaba donde
más me dolía
y me dediqué por completo a mi persona y
a mi pintura
hice una reestructuración absoluta desde
adentro hacia afuera y de afuera hacia
adentro me empecé a preocupar por lo que
consumía en todos sentidos
visualmente
en alimentos
en pensamientos hasta la gente que
frecuentaba tenía ganas de estar
de estar bien de estar en paz conmigo
misma
y volví a dar un giro de 180 grados esta
vez con ayuda de amigos de familia de
maestros
buscaba paz
para cerrar con broche de oro
me entero que voy a hacer mama tomar las
compras
ya se imaginarán
la bola de pregunta se volvió gigantesca
pero afortunadamente la vida me regaló
nueve meses más
para seguir con este proceso de
perdonarme y también para descifrar de
qué manera iba a integrar mi profesión
con mi búsqueda mi trabajo personal y la
maternidad
no tenía ni idea de nada nada lo único
que sí sabía era que quería ser la mejor
versión de mí misma quería enseñarle
algo valioso a mi hijo y descubrí que la
maternidad es una fuente de inspiración
mucho más intensa de lo que jamás
hubiera pensado
experimenta sentimientos completamente
nuevos
una fuerza inexplicable una sensación de
que una parte de memoria pero renacía a
otra una yo que actuaba de manera mucho
más consciente desde un lugar más gozoso
estable
y presentes
de alguna manera o de muchas la
maternidad y la expresión artística me
han ayudado a conocerme mucho mejor
a través de
estos dos compromisos
he tomado una postura mucho más definida
actuando conscientemente desde el amor
con flexibilidad y con humildad o eso
intento
y podrán decirme bueno pues he sido muy
afortunada en muchísimos aspectos y es
completamente cierto
pero como todos he tenido y sigo
teniendo que superar miedos e
inseguridades
nací en la generación de la crisis
no me acuerdo cuando empezó pero desde
que tengo memoria
está un miedo infinito al mañana porque
las cosas ya no son como antes
porque vivimos en una sociedad
completamente gobernada por el miedo
porque hay cambio climático porque hay
guerra porque hay inseguridad por todos
lados la lista no termina
además soy mujer en un país en donde ser
mujer significa que tenemos que tener
cuidados todo el tiempo significa que no
tenemos las mismas oportunidades en un
país en donde no existe un día sino
feminicidio
y además se cree que no merecemos las
mismas oportunidades se cree que no
merecemos un salario equitativo y para
colmo decido ser artista en un mundo en
donde la creatividad se regatea en un
mundo en donde cada vez hay más talento
por lo por lo tanto más competencia
y les podría decir
muchas más circunstancias que parecieran
limitantes pero realmente lo son solo yo
decido
y yo decido cómo pintar mi lienzo y yo
decido crear mi realidad a mi manera
y yo he sido
hacia donde dirigir mis acciones
y por encima de todo decidí ser madre
con el compromiso de no dejar que el
miedo y el adoctrinamiento dic también
en esa labor decidí escucharme a mí y
escuchar a mi hijo quién es mi gran
maestro del amor
y de la libertad he aprendido cosas muy
valiosas he aprendido a que hay que ser
conscientes de lo que consumimos de lo
que alimentamos a nuestro cuerpo a
nuestro espíritu de nuestra mente he
aprendido que somos responsables de lo
que decimos de lo que pensamos sólo
nosotros podemos decidir de qué manera
vamos a vivir la vida solo nosotros
podemos decidir qué le podemos ofrecer
al mundo y estar conscientes que si
actuamos con intención y con confianza
se logra la mitad del camino la otra
mitad se logra con el apoyo de otros sin
los demás no vamos a llegar a ningún
lado creo que tenemos que tener eso muy
claro somos una gran red
nos tenemos apoyemos nos escuchemos nos
queramos los ame monos
he aprendido que lo preestablecido no
nos lleva a la felicidad o al ningún
tipo de satisfacción he aprendido que lo
único que
podemos hacer por nosotros mismos es
escucharlos y actuar en consecuencia
carlos fuentes decía la libertad no
existe solo la búsqueda de la libertad y
es esa búsqueda la que nos hace libres
yo creo que la libertad está en decidir
cómo vamos a actuar ante las diferentes
circunstancias que nos ponen la vida yo
creo que la libertad no se encuentra en
lo externo la libertad es como la
confianza en uno mismo está dentro de
cada uno de nosotros
[Aplausos]
[Música]